[Music]
Titanus Godzilla's behavior seems to be
that the territorial animal Ashura
Serizawa theorized that Godzilla is two
driving force to restore balance to
nature whenever that balance is
disrupted suggesting that he essentially
considers the entire earth to be his
territory Godzilla has a symbiotic
relationship with Mothra she assists him
in their fight against Ghidorah and
Rodan using their webs to glue Ghidorah
to a skyscraper and incapacitating Rodin
after he fought her as she died Godzilla
absorbed her life force
enabling him to go thermonuclear when
Godzilla becomes the Alpha Titan he
doesn't attack mothers who follow
Ghidorah and instead spares them when
they swear their allegiance to him he
seems to be roaming the Pacific for now
Titanus Medora is larger than Godzilla
and each of his neck has a row of spines
that goes down but the middle neck has
two roses vines Ghidorah swings are also
much larger and more back like in
appearance than most incarnations and
they can also act as four limbs to
support his massive body Titans guitar
was first discovered in Antarctica
in a post-credits scene it is revealed
that Ghidorah severed head loss in the
battle in Mexico has been recovered by
fishermen from the ocean Allen Jonah
seeing the potential use for it
purchases it from a trader which is
probably why Ghidorah will show up again
in future most diverse films title
sponsor deviates from that of the
original Toho version and that she is
not a mystical divine being but rather a
member of tightness monsura a
prehistoric insect like super species
that originated from the same time
period as Godzilla and the other Titans
Godzilla species had a warm symbiotic
relationship with matras she was first
seen in the Yunnan Province of China in
an utterly original Japanese films the
motto featured in Godzilla king of the
monsters was worshipped as a deity by
primitive culture living in the yunnan
province where it's egg was stored away
in an age
temple where was discovered by Mona
after dying in battle against Ghidorah
it was later revealed that an egg had
been discovered its whereabouts are
currently unknown Titanes Rodin
possesses an aggressive nature first
seen erupting out of a volcano in Island
Amara he is seen destroying jets and
other aircraft that fly near him whether
this is done on earth defense of pure
malice is debatable
it is revealed that Rodin follows the
Alpha Titan regardless of the latus
intentions which is shown when he
submits to Ghidorah even after the
latter overpowers him after Godzilla
kills Ghidorah and is acknowledged by
the other Titans as the Alpha among them
Rodin approaches Godzilla and bowels
before him news clippings during the
credits revealed that Rodin has flown
too and made a nest in a volcano near
Fiji but is seen here flying over the
coast of South America Titanus comb is
shown to be extremely fierce and brutal
when anger hurling trees and the
incoming helicopters and smashing many
of them together despite this he has a
relatively kind and peaceful side
helping out a scare buffalo instead it
was trapped under a wreckage of a
helicopter befriend him Mason Weaver and
James Conrad and also sparing Aaron
Brooks comes only mentioned in Godzilla
king of monsters and never shown as he
ignored Ghidorah skull wanting nothing
to do with the other Titans beyond Skull
Island and wanting them to have nothing
to do with him in the film's
novelization Gore makes a brief
appearance on Skull Island before making
sure no skulls crawlers leave the island
after they also hear cadavers call
Titanus Methuselah is a quadruplet with
a forest on its armored shell with notch
white eyes and a mouth with large teeth
he also has large horns growing down
from the top of his head and curl
inwards and spines along his back and
reptilian tail he has claws for front
feet and who's for back feet concept art
shows that Methuselah appears to have
trees on his armored back which may be
smaller spines held in monarch outposts
67 located in Munich Germany
Methuselah hears the call of his new
Alfred Ghidorah and wakes up from his
slumber Titanus behemoth resembles a
prehistoric ground sloth with large
cultists resembling those of a mammoth
knuckle walking in way reminiscent to
that of gorillas he seems to be light
brown in color
and is covered in mammoth fur while his
head is that of a mammoth without a
Trump behemoth also has a row of small
flat spines running down his back
behemoth is contained and monitored in
mana outpost 58 in a cavern in the
border of Brazil and Peru designate
Titanus behemoth although he is known to
the locals as mapinguari
Titanus Silla is a giant arachnid like
Titan with a black coloration six very
long bony and light haired legs each
with two joins and ending with a claw
these legs are strong enough to jet from
solid rock and small space grow out of
the first joint so this hip is all
surrounded by several squid like
tentacles and unlike most fighters she
only has two eyes Scylla is in monarch
containment facility in a desert nearby
oil rigs in Sedona Arizona being
monitored by monarch and designated as
Titanus Scylla after her file is briefly
examined by Mark Russell sellers woken
by the calls of a new alpha Ghidorah
Titanes jinchen mushi are ancient
parasitic arthropods that evolved during
the Permian period of Earth's history
technically the Muto's are a part of the
smaller subspecies of the much larger
muta primal the Muto's reproduced by
killing members of Godzilla species as
well as the other species of Titans and
laying their eggs inside their preys
radioactive bodies like Godzilla defeat
of the Earth's natural radiation in 2019
a second surviving female Muto much
larger than the previous one was among
the Titans who awakened by Ghidorah
skull and converge on Boston the
creature dubbed Jin Qin mushi bow to
Godzilla in recognition of him as an
alpha she probably emerged in North
America
Michaela MBA or one who stops the flow
of rivers is a water-dwelling Congolese
cryptid similar to and believed to be a
sauropod dinosaur it is unknown if
titans Makela MBA was misinterpreted by
locals as decrypted or Titans Mikaela
MBTA was nicknamed by monarch due to
resembling decrypted in some way
although there are a few similarities
between them Mikaela MBTA is imprisoned
in monarch of post 75 located in jebel
barkal Sudan guitarra waves of the
dormant Titans and Mikayla and baby
tears free of his underground prison and
kills or devours all monarch agents in
the area
Titanus Leviathan likely refers to the
biblical use in which the Leviathan is a
giant sea creature created by God
usually described as a serpentine
crocodile or a whale this creature is
the counterpart to the behemoth
leviathans name may also refer to the
definitions of the vitam either a large
aquatic creature or a thing that is very
large and powerful Titanus Leviathan was
found an optimist by monarch an outpost
that was built around it
when Ghidorah calls Leviathan breaks
free office outpost and travels through
the Hollow Earth to the Indian Ocean
where it begins to hunt with the other
Titans Abaddon are also dubbed a talons
abadan is a prehistoric giant I guide
you created by legendary pictures that
appears in the legendary 2019 film
Godzilla king of the monsters as a name
briefly seen on a monitor before the
release of Godzilla king of the monsters
it was believed that Abaddon was the
Titan in Cambodia before it was later
revealed to be Typhon at some point
about him had a monarch outpost built
around it in man kupuna rock formations
Russia when Medora calls all the Titans
about and breaks free and begins 200 his
new pack when the Orca calls all the
Titans to Boston a baron does not arrive
in time to see Godzilla become the new
Alpha of all Titans Titanus organs name
may refer to the Sargon genus of beetle
possibly meaning that Sargon is a beetle
like kaiju created by legendary pictures
for the king of the monsters movie
Sargon was named after the ancient ruler
of the ancient Akkadian Empire but this
is unlikely to be related to titanosaur
gone due to the fact the Sargon is not
located anywhere near the former
Akkadian Empire at some point
Sargon had a monarch outpost built
around it when Ghidorah calls all the
Titans Sargon breaks free and begins to
hunt with his new pack attacking Mexico
when the Orca calls all the Titans to
Boston
Sargon does not arrive in time to see
Godzilla become the new Alpha of all the
Titans
Battlement are also dub Titanes Baphomet
is a prehistoric giant I guide you that
appeared briefly in one of the screens
showing the monsters attacking cities
around the world as a name briefly seen
on a monitor
Baphomet was a good headed demonic
entity worshiped by a cult and
associated with the Knights Templar it
is unknown if Titans Baphomet was this
worshipped entity or if it is merely
named of the Baphomet for another reason
at some point of time Baphomet mana
outpost Miller honor involve billa's
Morocco when Vidura calls all the Titans
Baphomet breaks free and begins to hunt
with his new pack like all the other
Titans and when the orca calls all the
Titans to Boston being away in Morocco
he doesn't arrive in time to see
Godzilla become the new Alpha of all the
Titans Tiamat was of primordial water
goddess and Akkadian mythology the
symbol of chaos of primordial creation
the name Tiamat is also applied to many
modern monsters for example a five
headed dragon in Dungeons and Dragons it
is unknown as Titanes Tiamat resembles
any of these modern monsters hence its
mana designation or if it was
misinterpreted by the Akkadians as to
water goddess or if its name refers to
something else entirely Tiamat was found
in Stone Mountain Georgia USA way mana
will oppose a tea tree around it when
Ghidorah calls all Titans TMR breaks
free from a sourpuss and begins to hunt
however even though it is in Georgia USA
it couldn't arrive in Boston along with
the other Titans Typhon also dumped
items - and sometimes referred to as
typhoon it's a prehistoric giant ikg
created by legendary pictures for king
of the monsters movie Typhon is a
monstrous and powerful male serpentine
giant in greek mythology and the father
of Scylla
he was one of the strongest creatures in
all of Greek myths and Zeus could only
beat him with the use of the
Thunderbolts it is unknown if Titans die
for is this creature or we just
resembles Typhon to some extent
similarly to how Scylla is the monster
from mythology but that doesn't look
the same as Silla in most of us at some
point I phone at monarch outpost 90 to
build around him in Angkor Wat Cambodia
with Ghidorah calls all the titles Thai
phone breaks free and begins to humble
his new pack 1 you've also dubbed a
tennis bunny up is a prehistoric giant I
guide you the Bunya is a large
Australian cryptid found in shallow
water it is unknown whether burnup
sightings are really tight on his podium
or if Titanes bunny was given its name
by monarch for a different and unknown
reason being the only guy to spotted or
discovered by mana dare down and ax when
you had a mana or post bill around it I
reckon when Ghidorah calls all the
titles when he breaks free and acts the
same way as all the other Titans but
being all the way down in Australia he
couldn't have reached Boston in time for
the coronation of Godzilla
[Music]
[Music]
you